hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
we're starting off with a game that I
actually don't know the name jus because
it opened do not a tile screen so we're
just gonna go and blind this hello hi
hello dark scary woods oh oh we need a
little more ambience for this oh now
we're talking
wait no we need a little more ambience
for this there we are okay this just got
a little bit spooky so I need to match
the spookiness levels if you know what I
mean okay I'm real slow I don't have a
sprint button and this seems to be my
top speed so I'm guessing I'm going to
visit Graham now I'm not a rocking-chair
scientist but I'm pretty sure there's
something wrong with that rocking chair
either that or ghost of Grandma has put
on some weight
Hey oh I'm sorry what was that
hey I'm tall by the way I'm real tall oh
okay
Oh 1968 huh okay all right well cool me
Torino examine ooh it's a can of beer
whiskey it's a can of whiskey well Emma
didn't know that why did that door open
what the frickin frackin duck that
scared the bejesus out why did it open
Oh trees of how and how many of green
you need to feel healthy flowers learn
about plants that grow fast and don't
need too much care just like me I don't
need you need to stop this you need to
stop this right now everybody whoever's
in here you need to stop this nonsense
because it is nonsense
hi ah multifunctional okay good good
great good great okay good great well
this is this is delightful this whole
experience is just gosh darn delightful
very happy about all that
okay hey I don't have a reflection hey I
don't think that mirror works right one
great big happy family huh okay uh
grandma grandma mom
Grammy mammy ramallah me cooking Pro
cooking Pro all right that's what they
call me the cooking pro you're really
gonna get me with classic jump-scare
sound effects three
all right cool yeah that's nothing okay
now that I've actually seen something
you'll never be able to scare me again
because now I'm ready for it so what was
that you know pray tell what what was
what was that
okay whatever maybe I'll go around the
side if I can no I can't this stack of
logs too high I'm too tall therefore I
hit my head on the ceiling okay so I
don't know where exactly I'm supposed to
go after that experience this door was
locked still locked okay great very good
great it's great this is great great
many great things did I mention it's
great all of this okay I don't think
there was anything else hidden here that
I could have possibly needed other than
the weird thing running by the you know
I'm just gonna get out of the house cuz
I'm beginning to think this isn't
actually a migrant I remember I actually
don't have a grandma
it's weird my family tree it's more like
a a family shrub just really wide but
not very tall it's it's really bizarre
no no grandparents are good and
invisible wall all right so what am I
supposed to do am I supposed to do
anything cuz I can't seem to get
anywhere there's not even a window on
that did I hear a child's voice
am I crazy did I just hear a kid's voice
all right so my guess is I need to find
something to interact with so I'll be
back oh here we go
what am i examining
oh whoa whoa rogue candelabra rogue
candala bibury Chris oh hey uh how did I
miss this
Oh found a door key okay I missed the
key who was staring at me in the face
Lix Ian cut around that make me look
really good
don't make me look like a big dumb dummy
remember I got the big brain so I can't
possibly be the big dumb at the same
time physiologically impossible me am
big brain all time of me I'm small brain
no time make that make that make sense
okay oh yeah I got the key that I had
already you guys saw that I got the key
I am very smart good thing we all know I
got the key right after that jump scare
happened right okay real hello hi oh
grandma MA okay I also just saw like
what looked like two eyes staring at me
right over there you guys can't see
what's on the other side of the camera
but it is horrifying
it's also late at night all good things
hey dog it's upside dude trick learning
for dummies and pros I am both of those
things close comparison of the newest
collections for dogs I hate you all
right cool great
this is good I sure do love grandma my
sense of style
Oh can't go in there are no going in
that room it's closed off for a reason -
barely
all right grandma must extended family
okay good
oh now I get a flashlight okay I'll take
oh there we go look at my hand slightly
diseased on there a few sores but that's
okay I got something grab Oh hmm yes I
don't need my flashlight in here huh
grandma
no you do not you do not do this to me
you don't do this to me not me no no no
not this time not ever not now no no no
Grandmamma Grandmamma gram Mimi oh [ __ ]
door opens grandma what happened to you
grandma grandma grandma that was my
fault grandma I didn't mean to sneak up
on you like that I know how excitable
you are I know about your heart
condition I should have been more
cognizant of your needs I apologize
grandma me mo grandmama mum yes I'm done
here do I run away at this point at this
point I feel like I would just feel like
I would just I feel like I would just
book it as fast as I can
away from this hell but maybe not maybe
there's more to explore I don't know
I've got no clear sense of direction let
me go back upstairs before I go running
off into the woods I don't know why
right now you know in in hindsight going
back to the place where I was just
attacked by demons and or grandma
doesn't seem like the wisest choice but
you know I'm just gonna go for oh there
was a note came back hey look at this
alright TV is truth thanks for buying my
kit have fun horror FPS kit okay is this
all one big ad for someone free made
assets for a horror first-person
shooters because if it is good great
more people getting into the scene I
like that anyway TV is truth so I don't
know what that means
Oh Oh all right off to a loud start off
to a spooky start I guess we're done
here then okay good that was um that was
a thing why did why why okay welcome to
Albion okay welcome to the borough of
Albion wasn't that the name of the game
or the city from fable or the country
from fable
I loved fable fable was such a great
game when fable two and three were such
let downs Oh was it Peter Molyneux that
Peter Molyneux God oh the potential
lines whatever Lions heads duty whatever
it was they made black and white I love
black and white no such a good game
black and white it was pretty okay to
Helens departure may result in unwanted
visitors to our beloved town why for
this reason the committee orders the
immediate and permanent closure of the
East tunnel why we are far past the
point that anyone we need to leave town
and we certainly do not require unwanted
the why why are you far past the point
of anyone needing to leave tip why why
is this some Silent Hill thing how are
you gonna get food are you gonna ship
all your poop out how you gonna poop I
guess you don't need to leave town to
poop but I think the poop needs to leave
town you're gonna have a poop problem I
don't know why my first thought is to go
towards what's gonna happen with your
poop hey you left it in decipherable so
that's your fault okay all right cool
hey Wow graffiti okay
well it's certainly I see the Pope I
knew the poop was gonna be a problem
it's always very poopy in these horror
Silent Hill style towns okay let's see
what we got going on here I love the
vibe I gotta say that I really liked the
vibe I thought that was the door it
reminds me a cry fear in a weird way not
quite but a little similar I've always
wanted to revisit that game after so
many years you know I never really did
the the official version of it and I
played it very poorly
is that a river of blood or is that a
rid of room poo
I don't know I'm walking towards it but
this feels uncomfortable okay
okay did not need the sounds oh oh what
happened oh okay
I'll follow you then you weird bloody
turd monster hey look at school okay I
don't know what I just saw and I don't
know if it was the same thing that you
guys saw oh well that's convenience
welcome can you hear it breathing has it
given you a name it is so good mind you
I'm glad you came okay cool good great
oh hi how are you hey what's up all
right cool good talk I'm gonna come
around you better be there when I come
back around hey oh you didn't go away I
don't like that at all
I don't know why I always gotta be right
about these horror games why do I always
have to be so unbelievably right I knew
they would have a poop problem in this
city
oh I was keenly aware the fact that they
would have a distinct problem anyway
good talking to all of you I am glad
that I am here and I you know I think
I'm gonna stay I understand do i no one
wants to leave this city it's so perfect
in every way every whoa I didn't notice
the sky are we in the middle of a
hurricane
cuz that sky is wooden getting down
there oh yeah there's something down
there
let me check over oh okay alright cool
hey hey hey good see it did Helen send
you the committee forbids the carrying
of sharp objects upon one's
you must be seen to be heard is that a
puzzle is that one of those puzzles you
puzzle in me cuz I am one not to be
puzzled with oh good great oh oh good my
vision goes a little foggy
alright cool good see a good talk
alright this is all good is very good
this is all good stuff happening here
all right hey wow you know I don't know
how I didn't notice that on the way in
and I'm pretty sure I know why Helen
left I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I
got a sneaking suspicion of why Helen
left I you know it's weird I understand
that it's what the hell yeah I decided
that I was gonna go knee deep in
whatever the hell that was and that was
gonna be good for me it was a good
decision I'm glad I did that
hey oh is that the East tunnel beautiful
thing
good evening please refrain from any
acts that may result in damage to town
property it is almost time you your
allotted shift to begin orientation will
take place in the factory entrance hall
great I was what I was about to ask
where orientation was I was about to ask
hey can I leave oh okay I can't go down
here but you know what I don't think I
do I think that was a lure I think that
was gonna be my untimely death if I went
down there I think I'm gonna go this way
where I don't have to worry about giant
bloody poop tentacles grabbing me in the
darkness
oh no there'd be a horrible thing no not
my giblets no no come on why do I think
these thoughts why do I do these things
to myself no please no not my I'm sorry
I'm very sorry I'm not sorry at all
I apologize for literally nothing hello
hello can I go in here no is this er
where the factory orientation would be
cuz I got a sneaking suspicion that I
need to go over the factory orientation
is and if you're not gonna tell me the
I'm not gonna be able to be oriented so
it's Oh apparently I can't go indoors
well this is news to me Helens objective
objection may yet be used against us
however until arrangements can be made
you work to continue to include her in
all internal bulletins it must appear to
all the other committee members that she
is being fully informed of all matters
related to production doing doing doing
doing you know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm saying yeah Kelby
could throw myself headfirst in there I
wouldn't have to deal with whatever the
hell's happening in here because I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna be scarred for
life for it Oh doing great good stuff
Hey Oh doors open hey last chance all
right okay all right that Joss is my
brain a little bit pit of death complete
yes please okay no all right blood let
me add mine too hi you here too or I've
been oriented the orientation is in my
mind I am fully orient eyes I have been
orientation aided the poopers within all
of us I think I think that's the lesson
I've learned here the poop rests deep
inside all of us if there's one thing
that unites all of humanities we are all
brown on the inside and I think that's
wisdom right there all right so um what
what do I do now I got orient oh hey
this is open that's good
I've been orientated so can I learn here
I go how many doors have I not opened
because I did okay oh I went in the
wrong room I I thought this was the
bathroom I mean maybe it is all right
there you have it
mystery solved mystery solved glad we
could address that - anybody have
questions say your questions now in the
comments below I will answer them all in
the order that they are received okay
we've been going strong on these we're
gonna finish it off with one called
upstairs and I am tall again and I'm
gonna go downstairs
screw your upstairs miss upstairs for
Lucy's oh hello can I get out I'll play
your game you opposite SCP oh wait seven
B you know I reference Oh eight seven B
so much that I bet a lot of you don't
remember that game or have never seen
that game before I know some of you have
and some of you are aware but I should
probably pick that game back up again
just to reintroduce you guys to the
concept of it because it's been like
almost seven years since I beat that one
and it is so iconic it is just like a
ridiculously important game in the SCP
universe because I'm pretty sure that
one is the precursor to SCP containment
breach and it's just really essential
it's really essential that that one's
known okay is there something gonna
happen here or am I just cursed to
wander forever funk don't like this
don't like what changed you loaded
something what changed you loaded
something game I know you did I know you
did don't douche with me don't dick with
mmm don't do doom come on don't dick
with me anybody behind me no okay if
it's just a cheap jump scare like that
other stair related game that I played
I'm gonna be real I'm gonna be okay with
that because I'd rather have that than
an actually good scare at this point
because I'm not mentally prepared for
something like that
don't don't jump-scare a god it's kinda
jump scare me I know I know it's going
to like that's
what oh I know hey how you doing hey man
Watson okay there's no need I am I'm
sorry was I supposed to skedaddle I
didn't know I was supposed to skedaddle
all right I guess I'll go for it this
time and not dick around ok spede I that
was really scary like not the actual
when he got me but was when like I heard
the second set of footprints that was
when I was like okay wait a minute hang
on here Oh like it okay so I'm just I'm
hurrying I'm scurrying and I'm hurrying
okay I don't remember there being more
candles that's new maybe there's an end
to this
maybe if I hurry as fast as I can I can
beat mr. Matt one-cent himself I don't
know what to do I don't see him is there
a limit to this this is never end
maybe that was a mistake
maybe knocking on the thing was a
mistake I think maybe that might have
been a bit of mistake okay there's
candles what the candles mean I know not
I don't know
I think knocking might be a waste of
time because I think knocking is gonna
kill me wait
and there's a glow there so I mean
there's candles up here by this door is
that important is this important
no parently not okay not important the
answer is it was not important there's
more candles I don't know what the
candles mean the candles gotta mean
something right the candles have to mean
something I don't think this is infinite
I don't think it's infinite I think just
like the developer copy and paste is a
lot of flights of stairs I just don't
know how many I need to traverse he's
got to be catching up like I
i [ __ ] around before but i didn't dig
around that much there's more candles at
the doorway don't know what it means
who got dark there yeah I would feel I
would get exhausted by now I feel like I
feel like I would get real tuckered this
better not be a endless is all I gotta
say this better not actually be endless
okay you loaded something does that mean
mister man's coming after me it's loaded
something I know it did what did you
load I think I hear slowly catching up
to me someone else's footprints I might
be mistaken but I I think I barely hear
this is never gonna end
it's been a while since I seen a candle
and I don't think the candles mean
anything now I think they're just random
I think this might actually be endless I
don't know I've been climbing non-stop
for like ten minutes straight and I know
that's not a long time but I feel like
there's gotta be something there's gotta
be something I don't want to go I don't
want to start going down again just to
end it I just have no indication if I've
actually made any progress or not
there's no rhyme or reason to this the
candles stopped appearing long ago I
think it's just a whole lot of nothing
now and I don't know mmm
I don't know seems like just a whole lot
of nothing and the only thing that I
could think of is if I start going down
either I'll run into the person or maybe
they program something in that if you go
up a certain level and you start not
seeing candles anymore that's a sign
that you need to go back down and then
either way I'm probably gonna meet my
untimely demise
so I'm gonna give it just a few more up
wait there's a candle speak the
Deauville there's a Gerstein candle
speak normal speak of the goddamn do
vowel well wouldn't you know it nothing
but it means a whole lot of dick and
Italy I don't know where mister dude is
though I feel like you would have come
up to get me if I had done something
wrong okay so I looked up and apparently
there's no end to it I don't know but it
seems like it's not and it seems like
it's not an infinite game right it
doesn't seem maybe I'm mistaken maybe
I'm crazy but this does not seem like an
infinite staircase in that it's
Julie generated to be infinite now I
don't know if that's for certain because
for all I know he's duplicated at 15,000
times and there is an end but he never
expected anybody to actually get to the
end so it's just like unfinished game up
there and I would love to say that I'm
like I'm gonna get to the top I don't
care I've got no life I've got nothing
better to do with my time
I've got no hopes no dreams nothing to
strive for I've got no I'm just gonna
play this game until the day I die but I
can't say that because I do have a life
I have a home and everything is going
great in my life I'm fine so I guess I
could stop this game at any time and yet
I'm still going I think what Avenue is
probably the murderer is so far down
trying to catch up to me that they will
never get to me and that's the problem
that's their problem
okay candle candle candle candle candle
I'm kind of getting more candles what is
that
[ __ ] hello hello hello
I'm not crazy is that in my rumours that
in this game
okay that was weird I thought I'd a lot
of hurt something okay alright I guess
there's nothing I don't know how much
more you know what actually I'm gonna
call it I'm just gonna say there's
nothing up here and as much as I hate to
say it I think it was a waste of time
it's a ruse it's all just a big ruse
yeah it just goes on forever so I'm
gonna call it here this is interesting I
like the concept but you know I could
have used like a bigger payoff I think
maybe there is one but I just don't have
the patience for it so we're gonna end
it there that was good
three good scary games for us to enjoy
in you to play if you want to play them
they're in the description below thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to check out more scary games
that I played oh I've got so many it is
playlist just for you linked right down
there to the description or in the
suggested videos right over there if you
want more scary games coming at you hot
and heavy subscribe today for so many
more scary games and ring that bell to
be notified of exactly when where how
and why I helped load scary games thank
you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]